robert cantor was addicted to opioids
for three years
it nearly killed him all my
relationships collapsed
my finances collapsed my health
everything on wednesday
faced with mounting lawsuits johnson and
johnson
the largest maker of prescription
opioids plus three other of the largest
distributors
agreed to a proposed 26 billion dollar
settlement
announced by a coalition of state
attorneys general
today's action sends a message to drug
distributors and pharmaceutical
companies
that we simply will not accept this type
of behavior
opioids are a class of drugs naturally
found in opium
poppy plants that are then used in
illegal street drugs like heroin
but also in some prescription medicines
like highly addictive painkillers
such as oxycontin and vicodin and
fentanyl
a synthetic opioid as much as 100 times
more potent
than morphine america is in the middle
of an opioid epidemic
a half million people died from opioid
drug
overdoses in the last 20 years
93 000 last year alone
and states say it's the pharmaceutical
companies
that produce the opioids that are mostly
to blame
not only for the loss of life but also
for the huge
financial strain that it puts on local
governments
and their health systems in a statement
the company said it had deep sympathy
for everyone affected by the opioid
endemic
but added the settlement is not an
admission of
any liability or wrongdoing and the
company would continue to defend
against any litigation that the final
agreement
does not resolve i don't think that
26 billion is enough just to end the
challenges the united states has with
addiction and overdose but it could save
a lot of lives
as for cantor he feels the settlement
now is
better than going through more lengthy
litigation
it's a victory because we have to
balance the amount that these
distributors and johnson johnson are
willing to pay versus the amount of time
that's going to be lost so we can get
these dollars for treatment
it might not be the end of the
settlements prosecutors say they're
investigating other companies
with involvement in opioids and are
leaving the door open
to filing more lawsuits gabriel zondo
al jazeera new york